most ordinary Parisians seem oblivious
to the latest downgrade by Standard &
Poor's even in this cafe opposite
Frances stock exchange the news hasn't
caused much of a stirrer but on the
trading floor it's a different story
French stocks have fallen more than
shares on other European exchanges many
traders see the downgrade as a sign the
government is not doing enough to
stimulate economic growth the French
finance minister has refuted that you
don't was appalled I take this calmly
because you've noticed that the outlook
for France has gone from negative to
stable even negative means that there
are risks of downgrade stable means that
the risks are thin and it won't happen
for a long time so Frances strength is
recognized and it's a country that's
trustworthy but at the same time I do
regret this downgrade but government
critics say SNP's decision simply
reflects the very real problems Frances
facing the ratings agency cited high
unemployment as a particular problem and
said Frances rigid labor laws are
hindering the creation of new jobs SMP
also says Francis debt is too high and
the government has little room to raise
taxes further in order to plug it
serious budget halls